so welcome everyone today big news out
of chestnut calm that this man Danny
wrench known for amazing things in the
chess world such as what you see above I
don't even know what to do here are you
kidding me
and so he has contributed many things to
chess calm and the just world we wish
him the best of luck as he goes on his
eSports career but I am wearing this
shirt here in honor of one of the only
good things I remember from my childhood
which was watching the chess bullet
brawls so okay now today's game is one
of Danny wrenches greatest achievements
he had a game against this man Hikaru
Nakamura recent US Champion and well
okay so they had a game right here and
this is what came on the board so Danny
wrench played Queen to g5 now here Korra
played very fast here as you could
anticipate maybe the near end she had
blundered he played this move Queen to
f3 which of course wants checkmate right
here on these squares but unfortunately
for Hikaru it was a real moment where
Danny wrench actually had not made a
blunder and he missed the tactic here
where Danny wrench played the move
played the move Queen takes the eight on
the d8 square now unfortunately for the
black king he must also now come on to
d8 square and this allows Danny wrench
to play the move Bishop to e2 Jack now
obviously here any self-respecting
person would likely resign being down a
queen here or actually a rookie excuse
me Ricardo is losing a whole rook here
because of this tactic but when you are
facing Danny wrench si Caro has status
it is likely never good to resign on the
board most of the time that there's a
hundred percent through of course unless
it's not and so the move 95 was played
here to attack now Hikaru makes
attacking moves and it's pretty clear
that Danny wrench has to put the rook on
the square so he does that and here many
people came to watch this game which was
being live-streamed actually to both the
Danny ranch and headquarters channels
and they all came in what they saw
what what they saw was this move here
they saw each takes three we have a
capture now of course hakuro is still
just down a rook which in most cases is
again it's enough for you to look at
what's on the board and okay so Bishop
therefore came on the board
King c8 came and now Danny wrench finds
one of the only ways to lose this
position as can be expected just about
any move should win here when you are up
a whole look this is what you should do
any move wins when you're up will look
something like c4 make a square where
the knight can retreat on the board not
letting your knight be trapped is
usually a good idea of course you could
also make some of like before which also
guards to c5 Square and gives your
knight of retreating square again any
move on the board
besides probably what the any ranch
place here is likely going to be okay
but okay I you know he has many fine
achievements in the chess world Dani
wrench not always on the board though
and he takes here and after takes and
the rook moves now of course we see this
move on the board and okay well then the
wrench is already losing back some
material and the karo follows that
quickly with another good move here on
the board it came to this to the square
that you see which is of course d4 and
okay so even if Dani wrench is not
losing yet now that you are playing
acara when you are only up in exchange
oh okay well we know the difference
between these two players I'm not sure
that anybody else would be able to tell
but okay as I said this is not the Dani
wrench from my chess bullet brawl
childhood not anymore
and so it's a five comes on the board we
see some some more moves that are being
played h4 to the pond a pawn goes to the
h4 Square excuse me we see some more
moves played on the board here and of
course trading pieces is almost always
completely correct when you're up
material of course unless it's not and
in this case
okay this move came and this move also
came on the board and now okay this was
your opportunity here if you're the only
wrench to perhaps save you
yourself and your chances but as we know
there's a reason he's leaving chess to
go to TBS all right okay so you can
clearly leave a comment in my in my
videos and give your opinions about
about missile wrench and what you see
here but as we know he did not play the
best move here he gave check which would
just forced this King to a good square
which my coach always said that checks
are for passers Danny wrench is he won
or not this is for you to decide okay so
he goes for these cheapest checks which
as we know are just checks and a hundred
percent of the time when you have a past
cheap on you have good winning chances
except not and here this is a not and
more moves are coming so before we end
the game and show exactly how Danny
wrench lost here against bishops in a
seemingly impossible position to lose
but he karo goes on to win it and okay
so I'd like to bring this video to a
close by saying farewell of course to
Dani wrench here is a nice photo of him
and of the chess world I appreciate his
contributions at least those that's
affected my childhood i III wish he was
still doing useful things in the chess
world but it's been many years since he
did so we instead say goodbye to him and
we are happy that we can move on and
again as I said thank you so much for
being here and and for enjoying this
night's video and that nice photo and of
course I will see you on another day